[Music]
great news for all fans of massive
action
the hollywood reporter claims that
legendary is currently in the planning
stages for another monstroverse movie
with the ass of yet
unofficially confirmed name son of kong
this comes as a surprise to fans and
journalists alike
as following the decent success of
godzilla 2 king of monsters the studio
had actually decided to call it quits
after the release of godzilla vs kong
now however they are said to be in the
midst of talks with director adam
weingart for the purpose of the sequel
to the film universe
the 30 year old who recently directed
godzilla vs kong would be the first ever
to bring two films of the franchise to
the big screen
it would certainly be well worth it as
legendary's latest blockbuster achieved
the best box office results since the
beginning of the pandemic
with more than 400 million us dollars
and that despite the fact that the movie
theaters are not even
open in many countries in case of doubt
though you will have to be ready for a
somewhat longer wait with wingate since
the u.s american
is quite busy at the moment with his
thundercats film as well as a sequel
to face off work on the upcoming mcu
spectacle guardians of the galaxy 3 is
in full swing yet james gunn did miss
the chance to hit at a small special for
fans on twitter
so far only the title the guardians of
the galaxy holiday special is known and
the 50 year old director has not yet
commented on the plot
based on the emojis and theme it is of
course clear that it must be a christmas
special which is set to release
next year the news didn't just trigger
jumps of joy however as star wars legend
mark hamlet commented on twitter with a
wink that he had a bad
feeling about the special die-hard star
wars fans are of course aware of what he
means as the 69
year old hamill starred in the now
notorious star wars holiday special from
1978
notorious for being so bad that it was
cancelled after a short time
and internally scrapped george lucas
also deemed the production atrocious and
is probably glad that the holiday
special
is hard to find these days and is even
considered a collectible among fans
regardless we're looking forward to
james gunn's hopefully totally awesome
guardians of the galaxy christmas
special
warning to all the falcon and the winter
soldier viewers if you haven't finished
watching the series finale yet it's best
to skip this news
everyone else can rejoice because disney
has recently published a poster with the
new captain america
just in time for the finale of the
mansion disney plus series sam wilson
alias
falcon gets his new cap suit from the
kingdom of wakanda
in parallel it has also been leaked that
marvel is already working on captain
america 4.
behind the camera the falcon and the
winter soldier showrunner malcolm
spellman and writer dalain muzon will be
responsible for the script
while there is no information yet known
regarding the cast
needless to say anthony mackie and
sebastian stan should be given their
respective roles
but we would also be excited to see
chris evans make an appearance for
example
equally pleasing would be a reappearance
of daniel bruhl since he pretty much
delighted the fans with his role as
baron zemo
anthony mackie definitely can't wait to
play the new cap
for as he revealed to entertainment
weekly on tuesday the clueless 42 year
old is believed to have learned about
marvel's movie plans in a supermarket
we are definitely looking forward to new
information about captain america 4
and we'll of course keep you up to date
on our website and in the weekly news
as usual the production start of the
game of thrones spin-off house of the
dragon was officially heralded recently
just in time for the start of filming
there are also first pictures of the
cast and the set
in various shots we get to know the main
character renora targaryen played by
amadarsi and king viserys the first
played by patty considine
also in the cast are matt smith as
prince damon targaryen
olivia cook as ellison hightower steve
tussand asked the sea serpent
and ray sivans as otto hightower it's a
bit of a pity that you can't see the
actors in full costume in the pictures
which is why we're all the more pleased
to see more shots from the british
tabloid newspaper daily mail
here for example we can take a rather
unofficial look at the two series rivals
matt smith and emma darcy this brings us
to the next topic
the story as in the original series you
can look forward to elaborate intrigues
and the bloody race for the throne
in house of the dragon the focus is on
the two siblings renera and damon who
would both like to take over the throne
of their father viserys
so expect great entertainment from hbo
but house of the dragon is not likely to
premiere on hbo max before
2022 fans of the netflix hit money heist
are eagerly awaiting the release of
season 5.
so far a common thread running through
the series has been that the cast is
continually growing this is also the
case for the new season where fans can
welcome at least four new stars in
addition to the majority of the cast
from season four
joining them are miguel angel silvestri
patrick creato alberto amarilla and jose
manel
sadly these specific roles of the
newcomers are still secret so we will
have to be patient for more details
should season 5 really be released this
year as designed by fans we can
certainly expect
new information soon
the annual academy awards were handed
out to hollywood stars and starlets this
past
sunday it was already obvious in advance
that the pandemic and the selection of
films meant that the viewing figures
were not really going to be great
however even the harshest critic would
have been surprised by
how poor the ratings for the award
ceremony really were
according to the us broadcaster nbc a
mere 9.85 million viewers watched this
year's significantly cut program
which is even less than half of the
previous negative record set in
2020 but now for the exciting part
the winners the critically priced road
movie nomad land by chloe zhao won
in three categories best picture best
director
and with francis mcdormand also in the
best actress category
the highlight at the end was certainly
the surprising award of an oscar to the
83 year old sir anthony hopkins who was
nominated in the best actor in a leading
role category and came out
on top almost ironically hopkins was not
even on site was not aware of the award
ceremony and then only expressed his
thoughts on monday morning via instagram
in a statement he announced that at 83
years old he had not expected to receive
the award and at the same time he paid
tribute to the late chadwick boseman
with a few kind words
this is apt after all just about
everyone had expected another posthumous
award for the black panther actor
as the first asian and second woman ever
record breaking director chloe xiao
accepted the oscar for best director
not an undeserved award since zhao's no
midland is one of the few glimmers of
hope in an otherwise
film poor era other winners were pixar's
soul in best animated feature film
another round in best international
feature film daniel
kaluya in best supporting actor and yoon
young in best supporting actress
did you watch the oscars and if so what
are your thoughts on the winners and the
ceremony itself
let us know in the comments see you next
time
[Music]
you